خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين لم يهدا هذا
القصر قصر باكينج فما لبثت ان تنطوي حادثه
العنصريه التي طالت مساعده الملكه
اليزابيث الرحله حتى اعلنت منصه نتفليكس
عن وثائقي هاري ومجدن هذا الوثائقي الذي
تصدر عناوين الصحف كافه بلا استثناء وهو
ما قد يتسبب بصداع للعائله الملكيه التي
عاده ما تتجنب الحديث في امور العائله
الخاصه
ايوه
الحلقات الثلاثه الاولى لا تقل عن ضجه
الاعلان الترويجي الذي تزامن مع زيارته
ويليام وكيت الى امريكا فاراء ثنائي في
العائله الملكه ستنفرت مؤيديها لاسيما في
وسائل الاعلام
صحيفه المترو ذائعه الصيت والتي توزع في
القطارات سنه هجوما عنيفا على هاري وماجد
سائله اياهما هل تضعان المال قبل العائله
واجابت عنهما قائله انه السؤال الذي لن
يجيب عنه
صحيفه الديلي اكسبريس
على صفحتها الاولى ايضا الى جانب صوره
لهاري والملك الراحله طلبت بايقاف ما
وصفته بالخيانه للملكه الدالي ميل والدليل
ضربه الراحله في حين تحدثت تايمز عن
انزعاج القصر من الوثائق ومعتضمنه
[موسيقى]
لعبه
المسلسل
من ملاحقه الاعلام لها بحجه ان هذا ما
يحدث لكل اللواتي يرتبط بالعائله ويتحدث
هاري عن فخره بان اطفاله مختلطوا العرق
وكيف انه فعل مثل ما جن وترك كل شيء
لاجلها
النقمه على العائله حيث تقول انها مهما
فعلت كانوا شيء يجدون طريقه لتدميرها
في الوثائقي يبدو هاري ماخودا بوالدته
وبالتشابه بينها وبين مدن من حيث التعاطف
والحنان ومن حيث الثقه والدفء هل يقول انه
سيفعل ما بوسعه لتجنب تكرار سيناري والدته
مع عائلته الحاليه هو لا يريد للتاريخ ان
يعيد نفسه وربما ذلك هو المفتاح الذي
ادخله القلوب الكثيرين الذين احبه دائما
في صباح العربيه من لندن معروف عبد الحق